hello everyone welcome today's live
broadcast manipulating the micro bone
microbiome to prevent and treat
infection I am Robert Castellanos of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event lab roots is the lean
scientific social networking site and we
are proud to bring you this interactive
web seminar for more information please
visit land routes comm this isn't going
to be an interactive presentation we
want to hear from you and this means you
can ask questions throughout the
presentation by selecting the green Q&A
button at the lower left-hand corner of
the screen and we'll make sure to answer
as many of those questions as possible
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon at the lower
right-hand corner of the slide window if
you can't hear or this presentation
seems not to be functioning properly
please let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button in the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing educational credits after the
webinar is over please click on the cee
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of attaining your credits I
would like to now introduce today's
speaker dr. dan de ghuma doctor de Gama
is the director of the division of
infectious diseases at the University of
Iowa Carver College of Medicine
associate director of the University of
Iowa clinical microbiology laboratory
the associate hospital epidemiologist at
the University of Iowa health care he
has served on national committees that
have established standards in clinical
microbiology and infection prevention
including the CDC's healthcare infection
control practices advisory committee of
which he is currently the co-chair and
without further ado I would like to now
introduce the doctor
alright thank you all for tuning in for
this webinar I it's my pleasure to be
able to chat with you a bit about how we
are currently manipulating the human
microbiome in efforts to growth prevent
entry infection so I'm just going to
launch right in here as most of you
already know humans are basically
walking ecosystems of microbial life
there if you count up all the bacterial
fungal and viral cells that we have on
or in human beings they outnumber human
cells a tenfold and the genetic material
as well much more abundant microbial
genetic material living in and on us
than human genetic material most of
these organisms are bacterial and those
are the ones that I'll be talking about
most today in terms of the ways that we
approach a microbiome manipulation to
prevent infection so one of the most
important concepts of human microbiota
is that it varies quite dramatically
from one body site to another if you
look at this slide for example for the
gastrointestinal tract you see it's
really overwhelmingly consists of
firmicutes and bacteria bacteria
oriented bacterial disease whereas for
skin microbiota you see a lot more at
10'o bacteria and as you go to the
different parts of the body you see
different phyla that are predominant
there are other factors associated with
variation of microbiota from person to
person a lot of post factors
environmental factors including diet as
well as treatment factors like exposure
to animate roval agents which obviously
alters the microbiota significantly now
as was alluded to on the last slide when
we talk about bacterial organisms in the
microbiome but microbiota 99 percent or
more of these are beneficial if they
weren't very few of us would still be
alive it's only rarely that one of these
organisms acts as a pathogen so the
distinction between a commensal or a
normal part of our microbiota and a
pathogen often just depends on the
situation and an organism that may
normally be a commensal can become
pathogenic when certain things occur
such as suppression of the immune system
or if a barrier skin barrier mucous
membrane barrier is impaired with things
like a central venous catheter
chemotherapy causing UKISS itís etc the
other way that a commensal can become a
pathogen and we'll discuss this in the
context of australian difficile is if a
normal healthy microbiota is disrupted
significantly that can create an
opportunity for part of what is usually
commensal flora to become pathogenic the
sites that I'm going to focus on in this
talk are the areas where we're currently
using manipulation of microbiota to
prevent or treat infection and those are
circled on this slide the Nerys or
nostril skin and the gastrointestinal
tract so let's start with the nodes so
this graph is from a paper by the season
colleagues in microbiome from a couple
of years ago and it's a metagenomic
study of the healthy adult human nasal
cavity they took 10 adults and they
looked at the organisms that were
present in the nasal cavity compared
with the buccal mucosa and the tongue
and the main really the only point I
want to make from these data is that if
you look at the aqua color which
represents a step-like oxide you see
that that really is only present in the
nasal cavity you see very little or none
of it in the buccal mucosa for the
tongue we
it appears that and and we've learned
that that Daenerys of humans is a niche
for staphylococcal organisms
particularly staph aureus anywhere from
twenty to thirty percent of humans will
carry staph aureus in the nose at any
one time so why is this important it's
important because staph aureus aside
from being a commensal living in in the
noses of twenty to thirty percent of
humans is also a very virulent human
pathogen and a significant contributor
to human disease staph aureus causes up
to a quarter of all bloodstream
infections thirty percent of our cases
of endocarditis a fifth of all surgical
site infections and over half of all
bone and joint infections or due to
staph aureus it's also important to
recognize nasal carriage of staff
because it appears that those of us who
carry staph aureus in our noses do have
a greater risk of infection under
certain circumstances for surgical site
infections this was first reported in
the New England Journal of Medicine in
1959 by Weinstein showing that those who
had staph aureus in their noses were
more likely to get staph aureus surgical
site infections other populations are
also at increased risk listed here
dialysis HIV population ID drug users
ICU patients and those who are recently
colonized with staph aureus in various
studies have all been identified as
being at higher risk for staph aureus
infection furthermore when these
organisms are subjected to molecular
typing study after study has shown that
the infecting isolate the one that ends
up being cloud in the surgical wound or
in the bloodstream is identical to the
isolate that was found colonizing the
nose in advance of infection so what is
the you know increase in risk associated
with staph aureus nasal carriage well
this is just three of the studies that
have looked at this and you can see that
in continuous ambulatory peritoneal
dialysis patients cardiac surgery
patients and hemodialysis patients
anywhere from a three-fold to an almost
tenfold increased risk for staph aureus
infection can be found among those who
are colonized with staph aureus mostly
in the note you know I should note that
staff can also colonize the throat and
the GI tract but most of the published
data looks at nasal carriage which is
most the site where it's found most
frequently so this leads to an obvious
intervention which is ok if nasal
carriers are increased risk of infection
what if we try to eradicate nasal
carriage or suppressed nasal carriage by
looking or seeking out those individuals
who have a carriage and then trying to
decolonize them using usually kirisin in
combination with chlorhexidine body
washes to prevent or eradicate organisms
that transiently colonize the skin often
from the nose so there are a lot of
studies that have looked at whether
screening and decolonization of staph
aureus reduces infection ways many of
these are observational before after
studies I'm showing you this study
because it's one of the few multicenter
randomized controlled trials by boat en
el published in the New England Journal
of Medicine now almost six years ago
what these authors or investigators did
is that they screened hospital
admissions for staph aureus using PCR to
look for nasal carriage and then those
who were carrying the organism were
given chlorhexidine with you kirisin in
the nose twice a day for five days
versus normal management the primary
outcome in this study was hospital onset
staph aureus infections and since most
of their patients in this study were
surgical patients most of the infections
were surgical site infections so here
are the results of this study they this
group of investigators was able to
demonstrate in almost sixty percent
reduction in hospital onset staph aureus
infection
through the use of New Pearson and
chlorhexidine among staph aureus
carriers and if you look just at some of
the most serious of Staph aureus
infections deep surgical site infections
you can see the relative risk at the
bottom of the slide was point to one
that represents an almost eighty percent
reduction in deep surgical site
infections due to stab Boreas so pretty
dramatic result this was followed by a
more recent study that was actually
coordinated out of university of iowa
here where marriage flights are in her
colleagues coordinated a twenty Center
observational study intervention study
involved over 42,000 surgeries so this
was really a pragmatic study to look at
sort of proof of concept is the
intervention that was done in this
randomized controlled trial if you do it
across a large healthcare system can you
also see a similar reduction and sure
enough when they screen for staph aureus
and then applied new Pearson and
chlorhexidine decolonization they were
able to reduce complicated staph aureus
surgical site infections by over forty
percent and the red box to the right is
basically just to show that they were
able to reduce surgical site infections
due tubal methicillin-resistant Staph
aureus or mrs a as well as it's more
susceptible cousin methicillin
susceptible staph aureus so why did this
large pragmatic study show only about a
forty percent or slightly over forty
percent reduction compared to the almost
eighty percent reduction in deep
surgical site infections that was shown
by bode and colleagues well this really
has to do with the difference between a
randomized control trial and an actual
intervention in a hospital which
requires really good implementation
because if you look at all the hospitals
and patients involved in this study in
the group and there's about forty
percent that were fully adherent to the
protocol in other words got every aspect
of the decolonization protocol the
relative risk you can see at the top
relative risk was point 26 on almost
seventy-five percent reduction if they
did everything that was in the protocol
so very similar to the eighty percent
reduction seen in the Dutch study there
was less impact if you were not able to
adhere to all the elements like maybe
they didn't get more than a day of
Harrison or they did not get the
chlorhexidine etc etc so after looking
at these data you might say well why
don't we just find everyone who carries
staph aureus and try to decolonize them
that would be one sort of public health
intervention to try to reduce the rate
of Staph aureus infections well the
drawbacks of that are first of all
decolonization is often transient it's
very difficult to decolonize someone
permanently up to forty percent or more
of patients that you give a staph aureus
decolonization were recolonized with in
about 90 days of the decolonization step
so it's really best performed right
before the high risk period so in a
surgical patient for example
decolonizing them immediately
preoperatively so that you carry them
through that high risk period for
surgical site infection and you may not
you know then by the time that we
colonize their surgical wound is healed
and they're at lower risk of infection
secondly if you were going to try to
track down all staph aureus carriers and
decolonize them you would that would be
a huge and really complicated in
impossible intervention because there
are over 80 million people in the US by
now that are colonized with staph aureus
and then finally anytime you widely use
an antimicrobial if we've learned
anything by now in infectious disease in
microbiology it's that exposure to an
animal covel agent will inevitably
eventually lead to resistance and the
compound we use currently most often to
decolonize staff in the nose is new
parison and we know from going back you
know more than 30 years to summer Carol
Kaufman's work in 1993 they show that
when they
tried to use me epirus and in the
long-term care facility after widespread
use the rate of resistance jumped to
eleven percent and most recently Mary
Hayden and her colleagues reported from
a very large study that used me Pearson
and chlorhexidine called the reduced mrs
a study they found that there was about
eight percent high level new pearson
resistance among mrs a in that study and
this is concerning because high level
new pearson resistance as many of you
may know is plasmid-mediated so it can
spread very rapidly chlorhexidine
resistance is also something to be
concerned about in this study they found
a very low rate of detectable resistance
and very few of the mutations that we
associate with chlorhexidine resistance
however I think we're still learning you
know how to assess for chlorhexidine
resistance there's really no standard
approach to doing susceptibility testing
so these reasons the transient nature of
decolonisation the widespread nature of
Staph aureus carriage and the possible
emergence of resistance those are
reasons why we don't try to seek out
every staff carrier to decolonize them
so now let's move from the nose to the
microbiome livid skin this paper by
Philip price was one of the early
investigations of the bacteriology of
normal skin and the disinfectant action
of trying to clean clean or cleanse the
skin the image is not from that paper
that's a scanning e.m of the skin
surface and the reason I may I show this
paper is because the concept in this
paper is one that I still use when I
think about the skin microbiome and that
is i divided the flora into the
microbiota of the skin into so-called
resident flora and transient flora and
by resident flora we mean those
organisms that are present virtual you
know all the time they're very adherent
to the skin surface maybe live under the
stratum corneum these are organisms that
are relatively low variance like
coagulase-negative staff staff including
staff at the
kareena for bacteria or different roids
and these are felt to be protective part
of the healthy microbiome of the skin
and generally non-pathogenic then that
by transient flora we're talking about
organisms that are more superficial
probably more amenable to removal with
disinfectants and cleansing and are
generally acquired by a direct contact
with with a surface or another person or
other fo might that carries the organism
so they're more transmissible and in the
hospital setting in particular we think
about staph aureus and mrs a
gram-negative bacilli candida and other
organisms that we sometimes see
transmitted from one patient to another
we consider those mostly to be transient
flora and so one of the ways that we try
to reduce the risk from transient flora
or pathogenic transient skin flora is
again using chlorhexidine and basically
bathing patients in the hospital every
day with a two percent chlorhexidine
gluconate solution there have been a lot
of again observational before after
studies that have looked at
chlorhexidine bathing I'm showing you
this study because it happened to have
been a randomized trial a cluster
randomized crossover trial in nine
intensive care or boner transplant units
in six hospitals the intervention was to
bathe every day the patient with 2%
cortex adine gluconate versus bathing
with bland so and the primary outcomes
were mrs a and bre acquisition in the
study group and hospital-acquired
bloodstream infections and the reasons
for these primary outcomes is because
those are the outcomes that had been
demonstrated to be improved in the
observational studies done prior to this
randomized trial and so I'm just showing
you quickly the results in this study
that bar graph is the rate of blood
stream the collection per thousand
patient days in the control group and
dark blue and the light bars are the
core tech city
group and you can see that bloodstream
infection rates were reduced by almost
thirty percent now many of these
infections were those due to coagulate
negative staff which is a lower variance
organism not staph aureus or gram
negative organisms but they also reduced
mrs a methicillin-resistant Staph aureus
and vancomycin-resistant enterococci
acquisition by almost a quarter which
was statistically significant mrs a
reduction by about nineteen percent in
VRE reduction by about twenty-five
percent so this trial basically
confirmed the benefit of daily
chlorhexidine bathing that had been
shown in other previous observational
studies and it's a very simple
intervention that most hospitals are now
incorporating at least in the ICU
environment to reduce the acquisition of
well mdro multiple drug resistant
organism including mrs a and bre and in
an attempt to reduce blood stream
infections primarily due to skin
organizations like coagulase-negative
staff now again we have to consider the
limitations of this approach including
the possibility again resistance to
chlorhexidine or you know there are some
organisms that are inherently less
susceptible to chlorhexidine and when we
start seeing increased our rates of
carriage do to those organisms i think
we still have a lot to understand about
the potential implications of widespread
use of chlorhexidine bathing in the
hospital so before i move on to the
gastrointestinal tract i want to at
least mention another way that we use
cortex adine to alter the human
microbiota in hospitalized patients and
that is a daily oral care with
chlorhexidine in those patients who are
being mechanically ventilated this is
now routine in icus around the country
and around the world as part of the
so-called bundles to prevent ventilator
associated pneumonia and it's based upon
the observation that most ventilator
associated pneumonia Tsar felt to be due
to organisms that first Colin
oropharynx and then through micro
aspiration events are introduced into
the lower respiratory tract and if you
can decrease the microbial burden and
really alter that abnormal microbiota in
the hospitalized patient you may be able
to reduce the risk for ventilator
associated pneumonia there have been a
lot of studies looking at this I'm just
showing you one meta-analysis published
now quite a little while ago actually it
wasn't recent but the cola meta-analysis
is the where the forest plot on this
slide comes from and you can see that
there was in when they looked at 12
different randomized controlled trials
in one of these meta-analyses in Lancet
ID they saw about a thirty percent
reduction in risk for ventilator
associated pneumonia so yet another use
of chlorhexidine to alter the microbiota
so now I want to spend the rest of the
time talking about the microbiota of the
gastrointestinal tract so the GI tract
is probably the richest bacterial
reservoir in human body up to a hundred
trillion bacteria colonizing human gut
up to a thousand distinct species and
the sort of composition of a healthy
microbiota in the gut is supposed to be
protective and it's felt to be protected
by providing what we call colonization
resistance so the presence of this
diverse microbial community protects the
host from particular pathogens that in
the absence of this community may have
an opportunity to cause disease a
healthy microbial community in the gut
is very likely to have many other
implications for human health which we
are just now starting to understand but
I'm going to focus primarily for the
rest of the time on Clostridium
difficile which is an anaerobic
gram-positive organism that colonizes
the gut and many people but it can also
cause disease
particularly when the microbiota of the
gut is disrupted so why should we be
talking about c diff infection well i
would say that in the US and in most
other parts of the world Clostridium
difficile infection may be the most
important healthcare associated
infection currently there are increasing
rates worldwide the increase that
occurred in the 2000s which is
illustrated on this slide from the
National Center for Health Statistics
was really quite astonishing these are
deaths per million population due to c
diff infection and you saw c can see
from this slide that it basically
quadruple over a ten-year period of time
and not only are we seeing more deaths
due to c diff infection we're seeing
more severe disease or treatment
failures more folks who need collect
amis because it c diff and we're even
starting to see more community onset
cases of Clostridium difficile infection
so it's a big problem and it turns out
that the main host defense against c
diff infection is to have an intact
microbiota in your colon there's clearly
some role for humoral immune response as
well can be protective but the intact
microbiota is willing to key here so in
every patient we see different virtually
every patient received if has had these
two events occur exposure to an
antimicrobial agent that's disrupted
their microbiota and associated with
either exposure to or antecedent
carriage of Clostridium difficile that
is toxigenic that is capable of
producing the toxins that cause disease
so what is the disease we associate the
CDF what are the clinical manifestations
well as I mentioned a percentage of us
carry construed iam difficile in our as
part of our microbiota in many cases
toxigenic c difficile but we never have
any develop any symptoms or disease it's
felt to be present in three to seven
percent of healthy adults up to fifteen
percent of newly admitted hospitalized
patients and even up to fifty percent in
some studies of long-term care facility
residents
most of the time it causes mild to
moderate diarrhea and is eminently
treatable response to therapy and 85 to
95 percent of the time the big problem
being recurrent infection as we'll talk
about but the more severe cases involved
a diffused colitis called
pseudomembranous colitis and you can see
on this picture the exudates that are
present on the surface of this inflamed
colon this can lead to bowel perforation
septic shock and death so as I mentioned
a big problem with c diff infection is
not necessarily the treatment as i said
you know well over 85 to 90 percent of
patients respond to therapy with
reduction or resolution complete
resolution of the diarrhea they feel
better the problem is the recurrence
rate which is exceedingly high the risk
of a first recurrence after you after
you have c diff infection is about
twenty-five to thirty percent those who
have a recurrence and then are treated
have an almost forty percent chance of a
second recurrence and then another
thirty percent of the third recurrence
and a fourth returns this is felt to be
due to the fact that a sea dipped as you
know exists in a spore form which is
very resistant to antibiotics era p are
really impervious to it so that perhaps
fours can then result in regrowth of
vegetative bacteria after treatment is
completed and the patient goes from
feeling well again to having c difficile
many of these recurrences require
hospitalization and many have severe
consequences so why do people have
recurrent disease well it's because when
you disrupt the gut microbiota with
antibiotic therapy it does not return to
normal immediately if it did you could
treat the CD stop treatment and then
expect the gut microbiota to basically
reconstitute very quickly and be
protected there it varies from
individual to individual but we do know
from some fairly well done studies now
that those patients who go on to develop
recurrent c diff infection or frequent
occurrences are those patients who have
a very slow return or no return to a
healthy diverse microbiota whereas those
who don't have recurrences are those
who've been able to reconstitute this
diverse microbiota and some studies have
shown disruption of microbiota for up to
two to four years after treatment with
certain antibiotics and some people so
this disruption of the gut microbiota is
long-lasting which is really why we have
such a problem with recurrent disease
which sicha the seal so this is where
fecal microbiota transplantation or some
call it fecal microbiota transfer will
shorten that to fmt for the purposes of
this talk that's where this comes into
play the rationale being that if the
fundamental problem with c diff
infection and recurrent c diff infection
isn't necessarily just the presence of c
dip but the absence of healthy flora to
keep the C dip from causing disease so
the goal of this is not to eradicate
necessarily osita but it's to
reintroduce a stable community a diverse
community of gut microbiota that
disrupts this or that replaces the
disruptive disrupted native microbiota
so there's a long history actually of
FMT in the veterinary field anyone who's
owned a dog for example knows that
animals often consumed their own feces
or other animal species this has always
been felt in the veterinary world to
perhaps contribute to the development of
the GI tract and be actually a healthier
adaptive behavior this has also been
used in veterinary medicine for the
treatment of certain gastrointestinal
conditions in the vet world they call it
transformation from what I understand
and so they were sort of way ahead
at least modern human medicine in
picking up on the utility of fecal
microbiota transfer so in terms of human
use of FMT there are some descriptions
in the Chinese literature going back to
300 AD describing using human fecal
suspensions for those who have
gastrointestinal conditions felt in some
cases to be a portable miracle cure for
those patients there is a reference in
the German literature to the medical
uses of human and animal feces and
references to observations in World War
two of Edwin's in northern Africa
ingesting camel dung to treat dysentery
so these are all sort of pre modern
medicine uses of fecal transfer to treat
disease so the the first sort of what I
would call modern era of Medicine
publication on FMT was published in 1958
in the journal surgery by dr. Iseman he
describes performing stool transplants
and he did this by taking stool from
healthy donors and delivered it be a
fecal retention animals too for patients
who had fulminant pseudomembranous
colitis so if you remember that photo
with exudative inflamed areas of the
colon that's what we call
pseudomembranous colitis at that time it
was not known that this condition was
due to clostridium difficile was known
that it had a very high mortality and it
was also known that it was associated
with prior antibiotic treatment so all
four of these patients improved and were
discharged home after this treatment so
interestingly really this didn't
stimulate at that time significant
ongoing interest in fmt so it really if
you flash forward now over 50 years
before we got the first real randomized
control trial
this approach to treat recurrent in this
case recurrent c diff infection and this
graph is from the nude study in the new
england journal of medicine at very
influential study that brought i think
FMT from being sporadically offered in
different centers to a more widespread
practice for the treatment of recurrent
c diff infection what these
investigators did was a randomized
control trial of three treatment arms
the first was the fecal transplant via
and nazo do anal tube and this was done
after the patient had received four days
of vancomycin and polyethylene glycol
bowel lavage the other two groups were
vancomycin 500 milligrams four times a
day to 14 days one of those two groups
also got the Pauline polyethylene glycol
bowel lavage this study was terminated
early because of how effective the
people transfer was as you can see from
the graph and the far left in eighty-one
percent cure rate which means no relapse
within 10 weeks of the infusion of
builder feces and then the cure rate
went up to ninety four percent with
repeated with a repeat for those who
weren't cured with the first with the
first go-round and you can compare that
to only 23 to thirty one percent rate of
cure without relapse in the vancomycin
group so this is supported by many other
case series another randomized control
trial and if you are interested in sort
of the aggregated data you can look at
this annals of internal medicine paper
by your kanya and colleagues from last
year they looked at 28 k series two
randomized controlled trials over 500
patients in the overall cure rate was
about eighty-five percent so a highly
effective approach to treating recurrent
c diff infection i'm showing you this
paper because i think it's an example of
the often really dramatic response you
see
to fmt and also the really sad stories
that you hear if you're an ID clinician
in practice as i am with patients who
have recurrent see get so this was a 61
year old woman with over eight months of
diarrhea just a horrible situation bowel
movements every 15 minutes having
essentially to wear a diaper at all
times had lost 60 pounds and failed
multiple courses of therapy to try to
keep this infection at bay well she
underwent an FMT from her husband and
within a day or two had her first solid
bowel movement within a month was
actually constipated and had not had a
recurrence of c diff infection at six
months and then if you look at the graph
on the right from this metagenomic look
at her fecal microbiota compared to her
husband the donor you can see what
happened so the second column is the
diversity of the patient on day zero in
terms of the flora in the colon and then
the donor is the third column and then
if the fourth column is the patient on
day 14 and you can see how similar the
microbiota patient two weeks after FMT
is to the donor on the day of FMT and
then day 33 you see there's still a
healthy amount of bacteroides there's a
healthy amount of the ruminal KCA which
is a firm acute which is also seems to
be a healthy part of a healthy diverse
colonic flora so anyway this I think is
a very good example of the kind of
individual results that you can see with
FM team so what about the downside of
FMT are there serious adverse events
associated with this approach and indeed
there there have been some reports it's
difficult in some cases even though the
frequency is very rare to determine
whether an adverse event was due to the
fmt or due to the inflamed colon from c
difficile infection for exam
well the four episodes of gram-negative
bacteria reported in this would be the
literature Baxter and Cole go look at
109 papers to determine the rate of
adverse events after FMT perforation
occurred in three sometimes this can be
related to the mode of delivery as we'll
discuss some FMT is done via endoscopy
or colonoscopy which does carry a risk
of preparation and then for attributable
deaths there were two episodes of
aspiration one was after sedation for
oklahoma scopic delivery of FMT and one
was aspiration delivered when FMT was
delivered via upper endoscopy so very
low frequency of adverse events but
nonetheless something to consider and
then of course there's the fact that we
know so little about the other impacts
of changing one's microbiota this is a
rather somewhat humorous headline from
The Daily Mail in Britain but it was
about a case that actually was
subsequently reported in open forum
infectious diseases last year and that
is of a 32 year old woman who had a
fecal transplant in 2011 for recurrent c
diff infection and got this the donor
was her daughter who is overweight and
as this Daily Mail story reports she
went from nine and a half stone to
twelve and a half stone with a BMI
increase of 34.5 after this now
obviously this is a single case but I
don't think it's crazy to realize that
there may be unanticipated consequences
of completely replacing someone's people
microbiota in my opinion though the
really life-saving nature in some cases
of FMT outweighs those somewhat
theoretical concerns at this time
so some there's a lot of remaining
questions about FMT one being what's the
best way to administer the the fecal
sample you know most often it's done via
nasogastric or nazo d duodenal tube or
endoscopy it can be done via retention
enema that takes a lot longer and it's
more uncomfortable and there's some
recent data now I'm using frozen
capsules and i'm showing going to show
you this study some refer to these as
crap souls actually these are this
report from jamming 2014 is an
open-label uncontrolled study of twenty
patients with recurrent seed if they put
about sixty six hundred fifty
microliters of the three coal slurry
inside each of the capsules and gave the
capsules daily for two days and 14 out
of their 20 had resolution after one
treatment course without recurrence and
of six non-responders five had
resolution one of those five did recur
within the six-week time period but the
overall response rate ninety to
ninety-five percent was very high and
there were no efforts offense notation
vomited thankfully and there's been such
enthusiasm for FMT that there was
actually in published in the clinical
gastroenterology hepatology journal do
it yourself home instructions for doing
FMT i did not recommend this but just so
you know this stuff is out there and
some of your patients if you're a
practicing physician may decide to
pursue it if they don't have the
availability of FMT within within their
area and they can even go to youtube and
see someone demonstrating how to do was
again not something that I would
regulate so obviously there's a there's
an ick factor associated with FMT and
even now with the increasing use of
school bang
which is what we do here we use a stool
bank to provide a stool from skreened
healthy donors and with the ability to
do look backs etc it's very it really
makes it much easier than doing a
related donor situations but even so
there is this hick factor so it would be
really nice if we could use a product
that is actually cultivate in the
laboratory and serves as a substitute
for stool flora and so this is what some
called microbial ecosystem therapeutics
I'm showing you data from two published
papers from the same group or at least
to that he was the was an author on both
of these papers in total in this work
they present 14 patients who had
recurrent c diff infection and they were
treated with a mixture of 10 different
bacterial species that are listed in the
right corner there you can see that
seven of these are anaerobes clostridia
bacteroides and then a couple of strains
of E coli and enterococcus they were
grown in pure culture then combined with
with sterile on normal saline and given
via enema over 86 eighty-five percent or
eighty-six percent response rate
patients became asymptomatic and no
longer had detectable see gift toxin
this is another paper looking at the
same general approach this was really
just a report of two cases in the
journal microbiome from 2013 what they
did was they took donor stool from a 41
year old woman in cultured 62 different
bacterial isolates from the store
including culturing under strict
anaerobic conditions they chose 33
strains based upon their susceptibility
in other words they were going to infuse
these organisms into the GI tract they
wanted to use only those that will not
multiple irresistible species and you
can see the wrong listed
right there and they mixed bees in a
ratio that was designed to try to mimic
the metagenomic data base of stool
samples from healthy donors they took
this final product which they called
repopulate and delivered via colonoscopy
to patients with recurrent c diff
infection in both remain symptom free at
six months so there are other published
studies looking at you know lab
cultivable stool substitutes I just
picked two well someone at random to
show you some of the literature that's
out there another approach I thought was
interesting was using bacterial spores
to treat recurrent c diff infection in
this study by kana which was just
published in the Journal of infectious
diseases they enrolled 30 patients who
had had 3 or moresee diff episodes in
this open-label study and what was
involved was taking donor stool from
seven healthy donors suspending it in
saline filtering it exposing it then to
one hundred percent ethanol to kill all
the vegetative bacteria meet only the
Spurs and the spores were from
firmicutes as you might imagine fifty
different species they were placed into
capsules the capsules were frozen and
then they were delivered in two
different dosing strategies to these
patients and had a very good rate of
overall clinical resolution at eight
weeks so another interesting approach
using bacterial spores to try to
reconstitute a healthy colonic
microbiota and then finally I want to
mention a paper that's gotten a lot of
attention from Dale girding in his
colleagues in JAMA last year and this
was a phase two double-blind randomized
control trial using non-toxic genic c
difficile spores to treat c diff
infection either the first episode of
the first occurrence and so you're
really trying to replace a potentially
toxic jeddak c diff and into that niche
you want to establish a non-toxic genic
see gift
community and so they had four groups
here a placebo group of forty patients
to see bode repetitive recurrence rate
of thirty percent which is typical and
then they had three dosing strategies
for the non touchy oxygen explores
overall the recurrence rate was half or
fourteen percent and interestingly to
take all of those patients who had
received the non oxygen exceeded spores
those that established colonization with
no oxygen exceed it'd be a subsequent
culture had an only two percent CDI
recurrence rate so I think this is also
a promising approach to treating
recurrent c diff infection I'm finally I
want to mention another very interesting
area for manipulation of the colonic
microbiota and that is to reduce or
eliminate the carriage of antimicrobial
resistant bacteria this study which was
published this year and clinical
infectious diseases by Milan and
colleagues look at what happens to the
number of animal Chromeo resistance
genes before and after a FMT in patients
who have a CDF and healthcare exposure
and you can see from in this study what
they did was they collected stool from
the donor and the recipients both before
and after and at time intervals after
two to four weeks for 28 in eight to
twenty two weeks and then they took the
metagenomic data and aligned it to the
comprehensive antibiotic resistance gene
database and what they saw you can see
on this table on the far left are the
donors very few antibiotic resistance
genes per person the bft column is
before fecal transplantation and you can
see it varied by subject but there were
some who had a lot of antibiotic
resistance genes probably because they
have been exposed to antimicrobials
which is why they got c diff but after
FMT you can see a really dramatic
reduction in the number of detectable
antibiotic resistance genes present in
the
fecal microbiota so I think this is very
promising and maybe a harbinger of
another use of microbiota manipulation
so that's really all I have before I
take questions in summary the human
microbiome obviously plays key roles in
health and disease we're just really
scratching the surface of how we
manipulate it to prevent or treat
infection but I think it's going to
increasingly focus on microbiota
alteration trying to restore a healthy
ecosystem and currently the approaches
that are in routine use our suppression
of the staph aureus Mary's carrier state
suppression of transient skin and mucous
membrane microbiota usually with
chlorhexidine and replacement of
disrupted gut microbiota I'm hopeful
though that future approaches will be
able to target the microbiota much more
precisely and I think some of the early
work we're seeing on replacing the gut
microbiota with something slightly less
crude than than feces you know a lab
cultivar oil solution i think is where
we're heading so with that I will take
questions thank you very much doctor for
that wonderful presentation we do have a
couple of questions here and for our
audience if you are still wanting to
submit some questions you would be able
to do so by pressing the green Q&A
button on the lower left hand corner of
your screen the first question that
comes in is why microbiota that becomes
have a Djinni or for example stiffly
stiffly Focus RS
um I'm not sure I understand natural I
understand the question can you repeat
it all right No thank you very much I
appreciate that for the clarification so
essentially the question is why does
microbiota become something to the
example of Stephanie Focus RS okay I
think I'm I think I know what the
question is so um the I think this
question was how how is it that a member
of the normal flora like staph aureus
living in your nose how does that become
pathogenic what are the circumstances
that allow that to occur and in general
what we think is that staph aureus that
is living harmlessly in your anterior
Nerys doesn't cause a problem until you
have some kind of disruption in normal
skin or mucous membrane barriers and
then because staff were raised in the
nose often transiently has access to the
skin if for example you have a surgical
wound or you have a dialysis catheter or
for some other reason you're
immunocompromised that organism can then
gain access and invade and then cause
infection so that's the reason for in
the case of Staph aureus that we think
it can move from being a commensal to a
pathogen and then what I'll do is I'll
just read a couple of other questions so
one is I heard that some people with
inflammatory bowel disease like
ulcerative colitis have used equal
fecal microbiota transplant with some
success is there any good data to
support that practice so I think that's
a really good question it there are some
folks with inflammatory bowel disease
who really do swear by fecal transfer
FMT to treat their disease but I'm still
waiting for a better data and I think
most of us are to suggest whether that
is in fact effective in inflammatory
bowel disease and I believe that some of
those studies are going on marrow so
then there's another question here is
there reason to believe that certain
antibiotics are better than others in
terms of how they impact the microbiome
of the gut and does that go into your
decision-making about antibiotic choice
so that's another that's a another
really good question and an area where
we really need more data because as
those of you who practice and in
clinical settings know antimicrobial
stewardship is becoming an absolute key
intervention to reduce antimicrobial
resistance and improve outcomes and one
of the things that we don't yet know is
where what is the hierarchy for
antibiotics in terms of how much they
disrupt the microbiota and if that could
be factored into our stewardship
approach and to our treatment guidelines
perhaps then we would see fewer cases of
seed if for example if you had a
treatment guideline that said here's
five ways you can treat a community
acquired pneumonia but we are going to
move this one up because it appears to
not have as much of an impact on the
microbiota of the colon that would be a
great situation so I think right now we
need a lot more studies to look at that
and let me just take one more look and
see
oh I think we've pretty much dealt with
the questions that have been asked so I
if that's everything then I will turn it
back for a wrap up well thank you very
much doctor for going through those
questions that's today I guess the final
question would be for you is there any
last comments that you would like to
leave us today uh well i think the the
main comment I would make is that we're
really just not just scratching the
surface in terms of the role of the
human microbiome in human health and
disease and the approaches we're taking
right now to me to manipulate the
microbiota are really quite crew and I'm
really hopeful that through further
research which requires for the funding
of to improve our understanding of the
microbiota will improve our ability to
be more as I said more precise in our
approach to preserving a sort of healthy
diverse microbiome all right today's
webcast will be available for online
viewing on our website through December
seventh and we'll let you know when it
becomes posted and we hope that we pass
this information along to your
colleagues who are unable to view
today's presentation we like once again
today the fine doctor and lab roots for
this wonderful presentation time and see
you next time goodbye